The lumbering ankylosaurus has a near impenetrable bony shell.
Consequently, she's unwieldy but capable of surprising grace.
This row of bony plates belongs to one of the most recognizable dinosaurs:...
...stegosaurus.
While the long-necked apatosaurus can reach high-level foliage,...
...stegosaurus feeds predominantly on low-lying bushes and shrubs,...
...so the two can coexist without conflict.
Triceratops is grazing here too.
This myopic ceratopsian might be seeing a challenger or a mate.
We can't tell.
His reaction is the same regardless.
He charges.
Stegosaurus's bulk, bony plates, defensive spikes and truly tiny brain,...
...ensure that he has very little to worry about.